revenons sur les propositions touchant
les années avec nous l'économiste daniel
denis qu'on retrouve ce soir dans nos
studios de sherbrooke bonsoir bonsoir
alors deux promesses presque identique
en apparence en tout cas annoncés par la
cac et le parti libéral pour les 70 ans
et plus crédit d'impôt d'un côté un
chèque de l'autre qu'est ce que ça
change pour une personne aînée que
que cette bonification en quelque sorte
d'aller jusqu'à 2000 dollars enfin faut
voir
des gens dans la manière des deux il ya
une différence pour les aînés ans parce
que dans le fond on a des arguments du
parti libéral c'est dire que pour les
aînés c'est parfois compliqué d'avoir
accès à tous les crédits d'impôt
auxquels ils ont droit faut voir qu'il
fait des années qu'ils font pas un
rapport d'impôt en soutien des aînés qui
vit optimiste parce que justement leur
facture fiscale avec la proche de
d'envoyer un chèque un peu comme
l'allocation familiale danfoss et une
station de s'assurer que ceux qui ont
droit aux montants vont y avoir accès
alors que dans l'autre est une
bonification des crédits d'impôts
existants donc c'est quelque chose quand
même que que les aînés connaissent pour
ceux qui en tirent quatre avantages mais
dans le montant en tant que tel il est
il est quand même assez substantiel mais
demain il va varier selon les niveaux de
revenus dans le cas de la quête consiste
une bonification d'une maison existante
ce qu'est ce qu'on fait dans le fond
c'est élargir le nombre de personnes qui
ont accès en tant que tel et on augmente
le maximum parce qu'avant c'était un
maximum de 411 dollars qu'ont avec le
crédit d'impôts existants qu'on peut
aller maintenant jusqu'à 2000 dollars si
on a un revenu de moins de vingt-quatre
mille chez les libéraux on est beaucoup
plus généreux à deux égards d'une
centaine
au départ le montant dans son minimal de
revenus pour avoir accès au maximum là
ça va jusqu'à 50 mais donc d'un côté on
ne 24000 pas avoir le maximum de 2002
rendre compte on a cinquante mille
dollars le maximum de 2000 dans les deux
cas c'est dégressif le dire que plus un
âne et un revenu élevé moins il va
toucher de ses prestations là jusqu'à un
maximum de renault où on en est il plus
accès du tout est ce que les aînés sont
davantage frappé par l'inflation daniel
denis ouais bah en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette mesure là
elle est présentée effectivement comme
une forme de bouclier contre l'inflation
c'est un thème qui s'est invitée dans la
campagne électorale de 20-22 qu'on avait
pas vu depuis des décennies mais c'est
vrai que les aînés sont plus vulnérables
à l'inflation pour deux raisons à la
fois ou deux côtés des revenus en tant
que tel les aînés ont des revenus qui
sont moins indexés en tant que tel donc
les salariés peuvent espérer des
augmentations de salaire générale ils en
ont à chaque année pas nécessairement à
la hauteur de l'inflation mais leur
salaire augmente d'un certain
pourcentage à chaque année chez les
aînés un grandes proportions importantes
ont des revenus qui sont fixes donc à ce
moment là la situation se dégrade
d'année en année parce qu'ils y ont pas
davantage de revenus alors que leur
dépenses elles augmentent et c'est
peut-être ce qui explique le fait que il
ya un niveau de pauvreté relatif quand
même parce que c'est à peu près la
moitié qui gagnent moins de 25 milles
par année puis particulièrement je vous
y reste et sur les générations des aînés
actuelle d'enfants souvent la retraite
était beaucoup mal préparés très mal
préparée il ya beaucoup de
sensibilisation beaucoup plus
sensibilisation aujourd'hui ça veut pas
dire que dans dix quinze vingt ans les
aînés seront plus riches mais il ya
quand même beaucoup plus de
sensibilisation il ya eu des outils qui
ont été introduits dans les années 80 90
2000 que les aînés d'aujourd'hui on peut
nécessairement eu avantage ou en pot
prix et il faut voir c'est du côté des
revenus et du côté des dépenses aussi et
les aînés ont beaucoup moins de dépenses
discrétionnaires la proportion de leurs
dépenses gérer de base est plus
importante et l'inflation a heureusement
été plus importantes dans les dépenses
de base que ce soit l'alimentation que
ce soit le logement et donc ils sont
plus frappés à la fois qu'ils ont des
dépenses que les prix augmentent plus
rapidement que le reste de la population
puis ont des revenus qui augmentent
moins rapidement que la population est
ce que la suspension de la tvq sur les
biens de première nécessité comme le
propose des libéraux et les solidaires
également est-ce que ça c'est des
mesures porteuses pour aider davantage
les aînés et les plus démunis mais
l'effet est immédiat un peu ses 1800 du
prix de consommation par rapport à une
augmentation de revenus dans certains
corps ont leur confère notre rapport
d'impôt dans une démesure dans l'autre
code une base trimestrielle externes
sont en effet dans le fond à chaque fois
qu'on va acheter un bien ou à une
diminution du prix il ya un lien plus
direct aussi avec l'inflation parce que
dans les deux mesures qui ont été
annoncées par laquelle plq aujourd'hui
on les a introduits comme des mesures de
lutte à l'inflation mais c'est des
mesures qui sont permanentes d'une
certaine façon il faut voir même que
pour le pq ou dépenses était une mesure
qui s'adressait aux gens qu'on voulait
d'enfants facilité de rester à la maison
c'est pour ça que ça c'est dans le fond
c'est tous les 70 ans et plus ce qu'ils
demandent et ch et celle des odac aux
dépenses c'est plus une mesure de
maintien à domicile
voilà on l'introduit comme le talent
inflation parce que c'est c'est à la
mode c'est important que les partis
politiques maintenant tout à fait
d'accord qu'une baisse de tps ou de
l'étude entre dans ce cas aussi pour le
québec un effet pluie béziat puis à la
limite on peut plus facilement le
renverser en disant ce qu'on veut on va
l'annoncer aujourd'hui québec solidaire
qui dit bon qu'un taux d'inflation va
atteindre 3% on va renverser nos baisse
donc alors que dans les deux mesures
qu'on vient d'annoncer jetons en effet
kalfon qui va être continu sur les
finances publiques du québec très
intéressant merci de cette analyse
daniel denis on vous retrouve durant la
campagne électorale merci fait plaisir
bonne fin de journée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit